I'm here with Adam hutler he's the
executive director of fractured atlas a
very interesting group that seeks to
fluff up the arts all over the world
correct I've never put it quite that way
myself but that's an accurate
description I suppose yeah we help
artists and arts organizations really be
more effective as businesses you've just
written in The Economist the existence
and accessibility of high-quality works
of art depend on financial subsidy and I
think there are artists and patrons who
believe that the Arts do need to be
subsidized but why by taxes Americans
involved in the arts often like to cite
how unfavorably federal funding in the
u.s. compares to federal funding in
Europe they kind of don't consider the
fact that the real subsidy that the
federal level in the United States comes
through tax deductions for charitable
contributions but the five billion
dollars in tax revenue that the federal
government doesn't take in because
donors are deducting their contributions
in their taxes obviously dwarfs the 150
million in any a funding I see that
people will grow skeptical and resentful
of the Arts if they don't have a choice
in its funding and when you give people
a tax deduction that is a choice I mean
they're taking their money and giving it
to charity or the art Milton Friedman
was a fan of food stamps because they
were sort of a market-oriented way of
providing subsidy for something that
society felt needed to be subsidized
that but couldn't rely on market forces
alone and I think the charitable
deduction is the same kind of concept
it's a way of saying there are works of
art that we want to exist that we want
to ensure that they can continue to
exist but that we can't rely just on the
market just on supply and demand so how
do we support that how do we do it in a
way that doesn't distort those market
forces and that is sort of as democratic
as possible but does art consumption and
expression have to be democratic no but
I think that's a much more democratic
approach than some central government
agency picking and choosing individual
artists or its organizations to support
and to the extent that it is curatorial
you know I like to see those decisions
push down to the local level you also
say that we must abandon the notion that
is strong arts Paulo
he begins and ends with public funding
why do you think so many people insist
on public funding for the Arts if you
want to kind of boil down the whole
thing to one number that an arts
advocate can focus on and pay attention
to it say okay the NEA is budgeted to go
up or down this year it's the simplest
most glaring metric out there and you
know it's a little reductionist to say
okay that is the symbol of our
government support or lack thereof for
the Arts again 150 million dollars in
NEA grants Larson what you said 30 13
billion in private Flint yeah that's
from individuals and that's just for the
arts of course that's from individuals
and foundations it's a small piece of
the overall pie and it obviously you
know becomes a very powerful sort of
political wedge issue which i don't
think really helps anything in the long
run a kind of government what do you
think can be done to encourage children
in the arts it's tempting to say oh
we're falling behind in math we're
falling behind in reading you know we've
got to really double down on our efforts
in those core areas and and that stuff
certainly is important yeah don't get me
wrong I'm not claiming the arts are more
important but I think there are two play
a really critical role in helping to
educate sort of well-rounded citizens
and especially as the economy is
transitioning from emphasizing
manufacturing the services to now sort
of you know what's talked about is the
creative economy having citizens and
entrepreneurs who have trained their
brains to think creatively and to you
know be in touch with different ways of
processing information and relating to
other people I think is a strategic
asset for a society I think there's a
lot to be optimistic about actually out
there I think younger artists and sort
of scrappy DIY small organizations are
kind of breaking away from a lot of the
old models of funding and support and
they're finding tools like fiscal
sponsorship or crowdfunding or or any
number of other tools out there social
media-driven or otherwise that are
allowing them to get the resources they
need to to make their work there also
you know increasingly and attack status
agnostic they don't think of themselves
as commercial or non-commercial they can
sort of move fluidly between those
worlds and I think that's a good thing
what is the best area for a creative
expression right now do you think I mean
I think the big macro phenomenon that
we're seeing in the arts right
now is this kind of breakdown of the
traditional dividing line between sort
of professional and amateur in the
balance I'm excited about the fact that
more people are making art is it all
Carnegie Hall caliber high art you know
representing years and years of training
no of course not but that's okay I think
there's value in the diversity of it and
the increasing universality of it all
right thank you very much at acute leur
a reason TV I'm Kennedy